hello everybody good morning to you
you're watching Sky News breakfast and
we start in the United States where Elon
Musk has completed his 38 billion pound
takeover of Twitter after months of
going back and forth over the deal
in an immediate shake-up of the social
media Giant's top brass musk has already
fired at the platform's chief executive
and finance boss
it's claimed they were escorted from the
platform's headquarters in San Francisco
from there our U.S correspondent Martha
Kellner reports
the world's richest man has been on a
charm offensive inside Twitter HQ
meeting a lot of cool people he said
having coffee with staff but any idea
that this deal would be drama-free was
shattered within hours when Elon Musk
sacked three top Executives musk's
takeover hadn't even been officially
announced when Twitter's chief executive
Chief Financial Officer and head of
legal Affairs were shuttled from this
building and told not to return it is a
power move and a sign of just how
fundamentally he plans to change things
here
he says he wants to make Twitter the
world's digital Town Square
I didn't do it because it would be easy
he tweeted I didn't do it to make more
money I did it to try and help Humanity
whom I love
musk has also hinted he will open
Twitter back up to the former president
Donald Trump some fear the billionaire
will reduce content moderation on
Twitter when abuse is still Rife
but he isn't short of fans in his new
neighborhood I think it's the greatest
thing since sliced bread really yeah
huge fan of them I think he'll do great
things it's long overdue I think he'll
get Twitter in in China and that's a big
Market
um he's had a lot of success in China
with Tesla
musk himself says he overpaid for
Twitter at 44 billion dollars but
believes he can bring half the world
onto his website Elon Musk seems to be
focusing on the idea of making Twitter
more free speech in his words what do
you make of that I thought it was really
interesting that one of his first
messages was to the advertisers of
Twitter
um and to say kind of don't worry too
much because if it becomes this Cesspool
of kind of hate and uh other undesirable
content advertisers are going to go away
so I think he said some of those things
but he's going to confirm confront the
reality of trying to attract more
advertisers
this takeover completes a seven month
long will he won't he Saga even by
musk's Mercurial standards it's been
perplexing what happens next though is
even harder to predict
[Applause]
and Martha has the latest now from San
Francisco
we're expecting Elon Musk to return to
the headquarters of Twitter here in
downtown San Francisco tomorrow to
address staff in a town hall style
meeting where he'll hear their queries
perhaps even their concerns about the
future direction of this organization
under his guidance and it will be
interesting to hear what sort of a
response Elon Musk receives particularly
in the wake of him getting rid of some
of those major lieutenants in this
organization and I've seen staff this
evening Twitter staff outside the
headquarters in tears so there are
clearly major changes for and it's
important to note that this has been a
long time coming Elon Musk first made an
unsolicited bid for Twitter back in
April he's been dropping crumbs of
information since then on what he
expects Twitter to look like under his
control less moderation he's been
suggesting of what users are allowed to
put on the platform but he did tweet
this week Twitter obviously cannot
become a free-for-all hellscape where
anything can be said with no
consequences there are major elections
on the horizon both here in the USA the
midterm elections coming up also a
presidential election in Brazil on the
horizon both those events are likely to
be plagued by misinformation and
election denial so this will be a first
real test of what Elon Musk allows to be
put on his platform it's a first major
test we'll find out very soon where
exactly his red lines are
there well I'm not joined by the
environment secretary at Therese coffee
very good morning to you Therese coffee
lots to talk about this morning but
first of all I wonder what your reaction
is to Elon Musk completing his takeover
of Twitter is that something to be
welcomed do you think look certainly a
big move by Elon Musk uh much thrilled
and started to negotiate early in the
year but I think it's a significant he's
decided to invest in this social media
site although Mitchell is a politician
at times it feels like an anti-social
media site but it's an important way of
how people communicate around the world
and we'll see what the next steps are
well yes he has called himself a free
speed absolutist he's been critical of
Twitter's moderation policies some
people are concerned that relaxing
moderation policies could mean that hate
speech would be allowed to proliferate
is that something that worries you well
I think that would be concerning
um and it's important that people have
these uh platforms use them responsibly
rather than to uh promulgate hate but to
it's also important to have safety which
is another reason why we're bringing
back or carrying on with the Online
safety bill in Parliament next week
Donald Trump U.S president former of
course
um still banned from the platform at the
moment Elon Musk in the past has
described that as foolish would you like
to see Donald Trump back on Twitter uh I
have no view on Donald Trump being on
Twitter at all um candidly that's going
to be a matter for Twitter okay well
let's move on to other issues you're now
Secretary of State for the environment
as of this week of course why is Rishi
soon like not attending cop 27.
well I've been to three cops in the past
and uh the UK hands over the presidency
Alex Sharma will do that on the very
first day of uh the uh of cop but I
think it's uh normal uh leave the case
that every five years the big political
cops happen and that's when you see as
we saw in Glasgow last year uh all the
different heads of state and prime
ministers coming from around the world
uh in between they tend to be more
detailed at the discussions but other
senior ministers including myself will
be going uh to Egypt to charmele Sheikh
for different aspects where we come
together to talk about specific issues
whether that's water nature energy but
the big push was happened last year in
Glasgow well yes but cop 27 is is very
important and especially at a time like
this especially when the UN just
yesterday said that the climate crisis
has reached a really Bleak moment and
the progress has been woefully
inadequate is it really the time to just
not show up as prime minister was to say
it's uh I'm not aware if say President
Biden or macron or any of those other
people will be there it is quite
standard practice that every five years
is the big uh the biggest changes
they're putting more emphasis on the on
these annual meetings well there's
always the annual meetings have always
been important I mean this year in
particular we're seeing also the
convention on nature it's called by the
convention of biodiversity as well as
one on legal trade of uh endangered
species so there's a number of different
things coming together so it's gonna
it's an important year for the
environment but we have held the
presidency for the last year and it's
important that we hand that over now to
Egypt but we will continue to do as we
are doing working towards different ways
of how we meet our carbon budget
domestically but also the support that
we give around the world uh to uh
different countries and how we take that
forward and we certainly showed
leadership last year when we really set
ourselves challenging targets and we
will continue I'd say to work with
Partners around the world to help them
deliver their commitments to but what
message does it send out to those
Partners around the world and given that
you're saying that the environment is
still a priority why then in 48 hours as
prime minister has Rishi sunak not only
pulled out of cop27 but he's taken alak
Sharma out of the cabinet and also at
the climate Minister Graham Stewart is
also out of the cabinet as well is this
a failure of leadership on the climate
issue is this no longer a priority not
at all I think it is very much a
priority and the Prime Minister said
that in Downing Street
um look I returned to defra I have I had
three years as a minister there before
as the environment and we work in in
Partnership right across government in
order to deliver our carbon budgets but
as I say the UK is actually handing over
the presidency on the very first day
it's important that we allow the normal
cop functions to carry on but I want to
reiterate several senior government
ministers will be attending and his
normal practice that every five years is
when the big uh if you like the prime
minister's in EDSA State tend to attend
um we understand or reports suggested
that Liz trust when she was prime
minister advised King Charles not to
attend cop 27 will he now be advised
that he can go under Richie sunac
um I don't I'm not aware that uh Liz
ever advised uh the uh the king of that
um but I'm conscious that um King
Charles has always taken a very deep
interest in the environment and climate
change and of course it would be up to
him to decide how he chooses uh where to
put his priorities in his uh in his
reign as king would you like to see him
there I think as I've just explained
earlier normally the big cops tend to be
every five years the United Kingdom
hosted that last year where we had
attendance from many members of the
world family but in between it tends to
be more of a I'm not going to say
low-key but not quite the same level of
uh of a heads of state and prime
minister's attending would you like to
see King Charles go to cop 27. I think
it's up to him I know that he he has
takes an interest in this particular
issue but it's up to him there are
reports this morning that Rishi sunak is
drawing up plans to expand the windfall
tax further on energy companies that
Levy stands at 25 at the moment will he
increase it well I'm sure that he's
working with his Chancellor Jeremy Hunt
to explore all the different elements in
the run-up to the medium-term fiscal
plan which has been put back by a couple
of weeks I think it's important that the
prime minister of course he was the
chancellor beforehand and can work
together with his Chancellor to decide
how best to make sure that we have that
longer term budget that will put us back
on the path to a percentage shed falling
as our debt falling as a percentage of
GDP but as environment secretary would
you like to see that happen I think I'm
not going to get into discussion about
tax because that really is a matter for
the chance in the prime minister so
you've got no view then on whether or
not he should expand the remit to
include Renewables as well well
um can I put it this way government is
don't have personal views this is about
governments going through that the new
prime minister will be working with the
chancellor to decide where to best
recognize the financial situation and
how we address that
can I move on to Northern Ireland now
because the deadline passed at midnight
tonight for politicians to come together
and restore power sharing in Northern
Ireland that that deadline has been and
gone the government says that elections
will follow what do you think elections
though will solve in Northern Ireland
well I think it's regrettable the
parties were not able to come together
to form that executive but the law was
clear we passed the legislation that
this would happen
and clearly not that wasn't sufficient
agreement to be able to avoid the
elections that wasn't in the hands of
the government that was in the hands of
the parties representing the different
communities in Northern Ireland I hope
that uh in the next elections will
provide us excuse me will be an
opportunity for people to reconsider
their approach recognizing the new
decade new approach agreement that was
signed only a couple of years ago and we
need to make sure that that we do what
we can to to work together to try and
make that come to fruition but
realistically nothing's going to change
is it the dup are adamant they will
stick to their policy of refusing to
return to power sharing in less than
Northern Ireland protocol is removed and
elections are just going to be expensive
and they could make matters worse rather
than better with with views and
trenching well the Prime Minister spoke
to the T-shirt yesterday and clearly
this is a situation of concern and
regret but I think both uh the um this
Administration this government but also
the Irish government will be continuing
to try and work to try and bring
together that government the formation
of the executive after the elections I
met the Deputy Prime Minister
last week and there is clear emphasis
that both our government and the Irish
government want the executive form and
we will keep up our efforts to do so
well is there any chance that you could
bring forward legislation that means
that the the elections don't have to to
go ahead well they definitely happen do
you think um they will they will
definitely happen
okay any movement on the talks with the
EU over the protocol well I know that
the Prime Minister has always wanted to
have a a negotiated outcome uh clearly
the Prime Minister was part of the
government under Boris Johnson when we
brought forward the northern line
protocol bill but it's important those
talks continue as well I want to move on
to the issue of um the Home Secretary
Zoella brathman and her return to her
position after after six days
um of having left it it still concerns
around her breaking of the ministerial
code after sharing sensitive information
Lord blanclet has now said that Security
Services could be reluctant to share
sensitive information with the Home
Secretary does that worry you
I don't think that's the case some the
Home Secretary recognized um that she
had breached the ministerial code last
week and clearly the Prime Minister has
now had a chance to go through this and
satisfied himself uh such that he
reappointed uh suela to be the Home
Secretary
um you know the very serious matters
happening in our country uh of course
our intelligence services and our police
will continue to work with the Home
Secretary giving her the full
information that she needs in order to
be able to make her decisions protecting
safety but of course also her main
priority right now is about the illegal
migrations that are happening the small
boats Crossing and I know she'll put her
full efforts into that and on the
subject of immigration Sola Bravo man
has said that she wants to get net
migration to tens of thousands is that
now an official government Target well
um as far as I'm aware the Prime
Minister will be discussing those
matters but the key priority my
understanding is about tackling the
small boats if I think about uh We've
stopped nearly thirty thousand Crossings
and just in the Sierra is my
understanding that's what I've been told
and I recognize there are a lot of
people here here illegally that's why we
strengthened early in the year the law
about how we want to handle those cases
uh but uh I think that partnership with
France is critical uh and indeed the
Prime Minister has been raised that I
think in his discussions with the French
President so no Target on immigration
um I'm not aware there's any change to
policy uh but Focus I think is about
illegal migration
ask you a quick question about Liz truss
you uh you've always described as a
close political Ally but you're a really
good friend of hers aren't you yes give
us an idea of how tough this week's been
for her how's she doing have you spoken
to her
um I have of course been in touch uh
with Liz and she's a good friend she's
with her family and I think she's
deserving uh enjoying a well-deserved
break and you were very close to her
politically and personally were you
surprised then that you were given such
a prominent job in Richardson's cabinet
well um I worked with the Prime Minister
previously when I was a working pensions
and he was
um in uh being a Chancellor I think I'm
known within government as being a
person who delivers and gets on with the
job and I was delighted when he asked me
to stay in the cabinet and to take on
the role of deaf secretary I've spent
three years in the department before so
I can hit the ground running and there
are many important issues to deal with
there as we continue to want to try and
make sure that we leave the the world
and indeed our country in a better State
and for future Generations than we
inherited well there is coffee thanks so
much for coming in this morning we
appreciate your time thank you thank you
so let's take a look at what is on the
front pages of the morning papers now
shall we and a boosting election hopes
for the Tories the prime minister is
level with Labor's secure stalma as
preferred leader of the country
according to a poll appearing on the
front page of the eye
Telegraph leads on plans reportedly
being drawn up by Mr sunac to expand the
windfall tax on energy firms in an
effort to fill the country's fiscal
black hole
the guardian though has a different take
highlighting the bumper profits recorded
by energy firm shell on the day the UN
finds there's no credible way to limit
Global temperature rises to 1.5 degrees
and the time says word on the Prime
Minister seeking a new deal with France
to curb Channel Crossings
now Northern Ireland is set to have
fresh elections Before Christmas after a
deadline passed at midnight to restore a
devolved government in Stormont
so our Island correspondent Stephen
Murphy joins me now from Belfast and
Stephen we just heard there from Therese
coffee that elections will indeed be
going ahead at what's the reaction there
yeah trees coffee pretty uh pretty black
and white there that there will be
another election echoing of course the
words of the boss here at the Northern
Ireland office the Secretary of safe and
ordinary Chris Heaton Harrison all eyes
will be on uh him and this building and
any statement that we may see uh today
it could happen quite quickly it could
happen in the next few hours he has
repeatedly said that a one minute past
midnight that's uh this morning in the
early hours of this morning he is under
a legal obligation to call that election
that of course because 24 weeks or six
months have gone by since the last
election back in May and the parties
here have been unable to form uh that
devolved government we saw uh the
dramatic action at storm and yesterday
the last ditch attempt to try and avoid
all of this which ended in Failure
because the dup the largest unionist
party here simply will not go back into
government as long as the controversial
Northern Ireland protocol still exists
so therefore the British government is
under this obligationally legal
obligation to call a fresh election here
in Northern Ireland and a new election
will solve all of this won't it well no
people here simply cannot see how having
a new election which will cost six and a
half million pounds in the middle of a
chronicas of living crisis is going to
plot a Way Forward politically because
even if you were to assume that the
results of an election just six months
after the last one will be broadly
similar I mean the dup May hope that the
unionist vote may be slightly less
fragmented they may do a little bit
better this time around but if the
result is broadly the same we have the
same outcome after a new election will
the dup put aside their concerns and go
back into storm and to know they simply
will not do that the leader so Jeffrey
Donaldson has been very clear about that
so when you talk to people here in
Belfast they simply are angry some of
them are apathetic about the prospects
of a new election they don't really see
how it is going to break the political
impasse but the British government says
it has no choice and it has to call this
new elections so all eyes on Chris
Heaton Harris today as he will lay out
presumably what steps he doesn't have to
set the date for the poll today it does
have to be held within 12 weeks but the
most likely day for a new election here
in Northern Ireland is a very Christmasy
Thursday December the 15th okay we'll
we'll wait and see whether that gets
confirmed later on Stephen Murphy thanks
very much indeed
do you stay with us we've got lots more
coming up on the show for you this
morning as that fresh election in
Northern Ireland looms I'll be speaking
to the former Irish t-shock John Brewton
about what could be done for power
sharing to return
and labors shout out Northern Ireland
secretary Peter Kyle will be with me
after eight o'clock
p.m back
sadden Summit I'll be speaking to
someone who worked at the last talks in
Glasgow about what this means for our
environmental goals
[Music]
eligible victims of the infected blood
Scandal and their families will receive
payments of up to 100 000 pounds today
from the government but some bereaved
families will receive nothing the
government says these are interim
payments and broader eligibility will be
considered after the inquiry well suburb
Chaudhary has been speaking to some
victims and has this report
only memories remain
Ron Ellis died in 1987. but the impact
of his death lives on through his son
mark
who kept his father's HIV a secret for
decades the perceived shame cost him his
health relationships and career but
today unlike others Mark won't be
compensated should have been paid 30
years ago 30 years too late
Ron was one of thousands accidentally
infected with HIV or Hepatitis C through
contaminated blood products between the
70s and 80s
and now by the end of today eligible
families should have up to 100 000
pounds in their bank accounts
currently only living victims or
partners are eligible I'm glad the
infected again
but
I believe that they could have gone
further and they could have paid more
um obviously
the way I put it is um
the Dead
they paid the ultimate price
this is why Steve has what he calls
survivor's guilt
he's been emailed saying he will be
compensated for his ordeal but some of
his friends won't
they've been you know thrown under the
bus and forgotten about this is decades
that we're talking about here so any
six-figure seven-figure compensation
divide it by the number of decades in
the number of years and it'll give you
an idea of well that's not actually that
much to campaigners compensation is a
start but it's also Bittersweet you've
got a long way to go inquiry will
conclude its hearings in early part of
2023 people are dying every single week
and not knowing whether they're going to
be included in the compensation and it's
not just about money it's about
acknowledgment of what happened
that's all Mark wants admission
money of course helps but it won't bring
back his father
it will however be one step closer to
Justice subordinary Sky News Swindon
China's Deputy Ambassador in London has
warned the UK against protecting Hong
Kong protesters after a man was beaten
up at the country's Consulate in
Manchester earlier on this month
protecting shelter to the Hong Kong
Independence
elements were only
in the end bring disaster
to Britain
I remind you of
a story of
the farmer and the snake in ethos Tales
where the
farmer showed sympathy
to the snake but finally bit by the
snake
joins me now from outside the Chinese
Embassy in London and how does this
develop the story this this statement
this warning here Milena
what it's a veil but perhaps not so
subtle message to Britain that if it act
decisively over that incident at the
Chinese continent in Manchester it risks
compromising trade links between Britain
and China the charge the fair there you
heard him talked about how it might end
up being disastrous for Britain to in
his words shelter the independent Hong
Kong elements he also went on to talk
about the importance of China Britain
trade links saying that China was
Britain's third largest trading partner
number one source of imports and he also
said that there were elements trying to
cause a confrontation between the two
countries which he said could be
dangerous and bad for both sides now he
addressed that particular incident in
Manchester saying that China had made
solemn representations as he said to the
UK government
urging Britain to judge the case on its
merits and not to to as he said bow to
political pressure now the government of
list trust has said that they would wait
for the outcome of the police
investigation to conclude before
deciding what to do with the staff
involved Rishi sunak who has only been
in the PM since this Tuesday has not
commented on this case yet but there is
a number of MPS both labor and
conservatives who are calling on the
Chinese start in that concert in
Manchester to be expelled over this
Milena thanks very much indeed
let's take a look now at some of the
day's other headlines and one person has
been killed and six injured during a
stabbing spree at a supermarket in the
Italian city of Milan one of those hurt
is Arsenal footballer Pablo Murray who's
on loan to the Italian Serie A club
Monza the motive for the attack is
unknown but police say a 46 year old man
who's been arrested had shown signs of
psychological illness
Amazon shares have dropped nearly 20
percent after the online retail Giants
forecast about about its all-important
holiday shopping period the company says
it expects a Slowdown in sales growth
due to high inflation and Tighter
household budgets
thank you
research shows nurses are working the
equivalent of one day a week for free a
study by London economics found the
salary of experienced nurses has fallen
by 20 since 2010. the report claims that
Rising wages May save the NHS money in
the long run because of the high cost of
bringing in foreign workers
British transport police have put out an
image of a suspect they believe
assaulted a man at a London Tube Station
then pushed another onto the tracks the
incidents happened yesterday at Baker
Street Station and Finchley Road station
just stop oil protesters have targeted
another famous work of art The Girl With
a Pearl Earring video shared online
shows one protester trying to glue his
head to the painting that you can see
there which is on display in The Hague
another appears to pour a can of
tomatoes over him the artwork wasn't
damaged but we understand that three
people were arrested after that
now Santos are examining two meteorite
impacts on Mars with the aim of
understanding more about how the red
planet was formed
amazing pictures at NASA's Insight
Lander is examining the site where two
space rocks crashed into the Martian's
surface each creating large craters and
the Lander detected seismic waves from
the meteor strikes which happened last
year the reverberation of those waves
along the surface is giving scientists
insight into the structure of the
planet's crust which may hold clues
about the origin and the evolution of
Mars
now for something that's thankfully not
seen every day in Los Angeles a mountain
lion was spotted on the loose forcing
residents and a nearby school to lock
their doors and stay inside
could be a bit long seeing that out of
my window the animal managed to evade
Wildlife officers for hours before they
were finally able to tranquilize and
capture it and they later released the
cougar back into the wild
a big cat to have in your back Garden uh
a reminder of our top stories now here
this morning and uh Elon Musk has
completed his 44 billion takeover of
Twitter and immediately sacked several
senior Executives from the company
snap election in Northern Ireland is
expected within weeks after the deadline
to restore the devolved government
expired at midnight
and the Prime Minister has been accused
of a failure of leadership for deciding
to not attend the cop 27 climate Summit
with more on that the environment
secretary has defended the prime
minister's decision not to attend saying
heads of state normally only attend
every five years Therese Coffey also
told the program it would be up to King
Charles whether he decides to go
I'm not aware that uh Liz ever advised
the the king of that but I'm conscious
that King Charles has always taken a
very deep interest in the environment
and climate change and of course it
would be up to him to decide how he
chooses uh where to put his priorities
in his uh in his reign as king would you
like to see King Charles go to cop 27. I
think it's up to him I know that he
takes an interest in this particular
issue but it's up to him
well our political correspondent Ali
Fortescue is here with me this morning
very good morning to you and so Terry's
Coffee there really playing down this
decision by Richie soon act not to go to
cop27 says that the government is still
very committed to environmental policies
yeah she says that he has shown
leadership I think that the problem is
he said he's not going to cop27 we know
that um alak Sharma who's a president of
was was the president of cop26 is now
not attending cabinet we know that
Graham Stewart a climate minister is not
attending cabinet so I think when you
take all those things in the round there
have been accusations certainly from
labor there is this a still a government
priority of course their defense will be
that on the 17th of November there is
this big budget this moment that the
government want to set out how they are
going to help to fill that spending that
funding Gap what that's going to mean
painful decisions potentially ahead so
the Prime Minister saying you know he's
very much focused on domestic issues we
heard Therese coffee there defending him
saying he is show leadership on on
climate change and saying that actually
usually every five years is when we have
these these big Summits but the reality
is the climate problem is obviously not
getting any better we had These Warnings
yesterday from the UN that there is no
credible Pathway to keeping 1.5 alive so
there is pressure on him will we perhaps
now see the king going we don't know the
government making clear they don't want
to get involved in that previously under
Liz truss it seemed like he wasn't going
maybe that could change and take some of
the heat off Rishi sunak yes that'd be
really interesting I won't say it and
I'm sure labor will have a word sale too
as well about got27 be interesting to
see what they say Ali for the moment
thanks very much indeed
now Northern Ireland is set to have a
fresh election this year after the
deadline to restore a devolved
government in Stormont past the dep has
blocked the restoration of the crucial
power sharing agreement because of
disagreements about the post-brexit
trade deal well let's get a view on this
now from John Bruton who's the former
prime minister of Ireland and former
ambassador of the European Union to the
United States John Bruton a very good
morning to you thanks so much for
talking to us what do you make of the
failure to restore power shattering in
Northern Ireland deadline missed at
midnight
well basically they ran out of time and
this decision was thereby inevitable and
the problem is that there hasn't been a
negotiation of a serious character going
on for several months now between the UK
government and the European Union on the
board I understand the EU is prepared to
make substantial concessions in the
direction of what the UK wants reducing
the number of checks by up to 90 percent
uh reducing the amount of forms to be
fitted I gather the form has gone from
30 pages down to three pages that need
to be filled and so the EU is working
hard on painting a picture for the UK as
to what could be achieved if they would
enter into serious negotiation the
difficulty is that as long as the UK is
talking about negotiation but also
threatening to abrogate the entire
protocol and introduce uh retained EU
law that would abolish all EU standards
in the UK whether they've been examiner
Enough by the end of 2023 that creates
an atmosphere of instability which makes
negotiation more difficult so I think we
need to use the time
away from the election campaign through
reinitiate negotiations of a serious
character between the UK and the
European Union Commission
in the meantime though elections will be
triggered do you think that can achieve
something
not particularly but it's part of what
is provided from the agreements and
obviously to have postponed the election
would I think have
diminish The credibility of the
Secretary of State he needed to make
sure that people understood that he says
something is going to happen it will
happen and that enhances its credibility
so this is the process we've got to go
through I don't expect the result will
make much difference perhaps the ducp
position may be slightly strengthened
vis-a-vis the traditional unionist voice
which may give them a little bit more
room for maneuver but it won't be
substantial the big thing is to get a
negotiation which has to be very
complicated complex negotiation because
obviously the parties in Northern I
didn't have to be involved the UK
government has to be involved the
European commission has to be involved
but so also the Irish government and the
governments of the other member states
of the European Union who have an
interest in checking the Integrity of
the single Marcus and Ireland as part of
the singular markers which has been a
huge economic benefit for Ireland being
in the zinc and matters all those
interests have to be
conciliated and we've got to reach an
agreement as to timing so that everybody
makes their concessions at the same time
and that we all are able to if you like
jump at the same time towards an
agreement and that that's is an
immensely complex exercise of both
substance and timing
well yes and do you feel that movement
though is heading in the right direction
you talk about some of the owners being
on the UK government and it's in its
role in negotiations we've seen some
shifting in position haven't we Steve
Baker Northern Ireland Minister
apologized to the EU and the Irish
government for the attitude taken by him
and some others in the conservative
party do gestures like that make a
difference
oh absolutely I think that was a very
very good and a brave thing for him to
have done and I I think it's all it's
important to get the tone right but it's
also important to get the substance
right and there is always the a big
difficulty if the
um essentially the UK's unilateral
protocol abolition Bill if that's being
processed vigorously and if the retained
EU law bill is being processed
vigorously that makes negotiation much
more difficult so we've got to find a
pause so to speak during which
negotiation can take place and that
pause probably will have to wait until
after the storm's election is over and
then a period when of intense effort on
all sides time bound to find a solution
that's reasonable for everybody and
nobody is going to guess all they want
we've got everybody's going to have to
give some ground the EU will have to
give some ground a little really
indicators what it might give the UK the
Northern Ireland parties and the Irish
government will all have to accept
somewhat less than they would like in
their Ideal World
you mentioned that the protocol
abolition bill you think that that is
problematic while the UK government
negotiates with the EU but some might
argue that it gives the British
government leverage in those talks it
shows that the government means business
and it and it strengthens their
negotiating stance
I think that notion of Leverage in a
negotiation that's supposed to be based
on Mutual trust is almost contradictory
it suggests bad faith or distrust and I
think the UK should at least approach
the negotiations with the European
commission initially on the basis of
good faith and accepting the good faith
of the people on the other side and
using you know off-stage threats like uh
the protocol bill as a lever
is not good from the point of view of
creating the right atmosphere for
negotiation
um I remember what this bill is doing is
attempting unilaterally to abrogate a
solemn International treaty and that's
something that Britain has not been
inclined to do indeed over the 19th and
20th centuries Britain was the greatest
champion of the Integrity of
international series and very hard on
countries that broke International trees
the obligations Britain should I think
apply that principle to itself
so we look like we're on track for
another set of elections in Northern
Ireland the second this year I mean how
is can that be justified I mean the cost
is being put at six and a half million
pounds I mean this is a cost of living
crisis that's going on at the moment is
it really necessary
it is necessary under the agreements
that's the the agreements we reached and
that's what the law says and I don't
think we should be putting a price on
elections elections are a necessary
process for Consulting people and there
are problems in Northern Ireland there
are deep divisions the majority of
people in Northern Ireland want to go
ahead with an executive one major part
of the dup which is a minority party but
a big minority says it will not go ahead
unless there are adjustments to approach
Club that needs to be discussed and
there's probably no better atmosphere in
which to discuss the options and to test
public opinion than an election campaign
I don't I think elections are a crucial
part of democracy they're not a full
expression of democracy but the
recruiting part of it I don't see any
problem there and I don't think we
should ever be putting a price tag tag
on elections
okay well John Bruton uh former t-shock
we really appreciate your time and and
your thoughts today thanks very much
indeed the production of the first coins
featuring King Charles's portrait has
started at the Royal Mint the new 50
pence coin which honors the new monarchs
late mother the queen will go into
circulation before the end of the year
sky is Becky Cottrell went to the Royal
Mint for a sneak preview
history in the making quite literally
these are the first coins featuring King
Charles III and these 50 pence pieces
also pay a special tribute to his mother
the reverse is a replica of the coin
produced to celebrate her coronation
back in 1953. So anyone under 50 will
only have ever seen Queen Elizabeth II
on the coin so significant moment today
where we're putting a new monarch into
that circulation so it's quite common
for male Monica not to wear a crown on
their coinage it happened to his father
his grandfather well they were on
coinage there was no crowd if you're
particularly observant you'll notice
that his majesty is facing the opposite
direction to Queen Elizabeth II on the
coins that we currently use that is in
keeping with tradition when there's a
new monarch the portrait was designed by
sculptor Martin Jennings using photos
and was personally approved by the king
it has to be an image that will persist
over the years and that will represent
the generality of what people imagine
monarchy to be about so it's not just a
portrait of him it's also it needs to
contain the role we'll still have coins
with the Effigy of Queen Elizabeth II
they'll only be replaced once they're
worn or damaged but you won't have to
wait long for these which could start
appearing in your change in December
Becky Cottrell Sky News the Royal Mint
has been reporting this morning eligible
victims of the infected blood Scandal
and their families will receive payments
of up to a hundred thousand pounds today
from the government but some bereaved
families will receive nothing I'm joined
Now by Michelle Tolley who was infected
with a life-threatening disease when she
had a blood transfusion in the 1980s so
Michelle tolly thanks so much for
talking to us this morning we really
appreciate it tell us a little bit more
about your experience and what happened
to you
okay well I received a blood transfusion
in 1987 after the birth of our first son
and unfortunately in that blood
transfusion was hepatitis C that was in
1987. I wasn't diagnosed until the end
of 2015. so I've campaigned
um since I've been infected to reach out
to find those people that are still
infected out there and that to help call
on for this inquiry that's Now sort of
coming to a close
well yes and tell us a little bit about
you will you receive compensation
yourself are you eligible under this
scheme yes I'm one of the beneficiaries
that are eligible there are only two
sets of beneficiaries eligible at the
moment that's for the people infected
like myself and for the bereaved
Partners widows widowers and partners of
the people that have tragically died and
lost their lives to this horrific
Injustice that's happened to us all and
I'd like to say that this is only an
interim compensation payment and we're
waiting for so Brian Lang staffs for
report that we're looking forward to you
know that it will be coming in next
summer
thing that we want included the people
the cohorts of people that not included
this time round so people that was
infected post 1991 there are people out
there that still receive contaminated
blood that are not aware of that people
that lost sadly sadly and tragically
lost their children to have tried to see
HIV and other pathogens for the children
that lost their parents there's people
who serve cleared hepatitis C that are
not entitled to anything although there
was infected by by the contaminated
blood and there's the people whose
medical records that we destroyed and as
we've been hearing over the time from
the inquiry that have um accidentally uh
gone missing so there are lots and lots
of people today that will not be
receiving that money but I for one and I
know a lot of our fellow campaigners
whether we've received this interim
compensation or not we will not stop
fighting and campaigning until every
body is included in these schemes
because basically this should never have
happened you know we should never have
been given a death sentence for
committing no crimes
and the government does say that the
interim compensation payments they say
that they meet the recommendations set
out by Sir Brian langstaff's interim
report in full but there is more work to
be done they're looking at a broader
eligibility recommendations made by Sir
Robert Francis at QC do you accept that
the right kind of work is being done to
make sure that everybody who should be
compensated is
oh yeah absolutely I mean we're working
hard now on submissions and ready to go
in ready you know for Supply so Brian to
write his report
um so there's still a lot of work to be
done this is this is the first stage
um for me it shows finally that the
government uh are beginning to realize
what a historic tragedy has happened and
why people of thousands of people that
have died have never received a penny
it's so wrong but I always try to leave
things on a positive it's it's a
positive step forward from the
government to call it into compensation
you know at the end of the day they've
got a duty of care they need to look
after their people and that were
contaminated people's lives were damaged
and lives lost those lives no amount of
money can bring those lives lost a
hundred thousand pound might sound a lot
of money but for me when you divide that
by my 35 years and contamination it it
really is pennies it really it's it's
just nothing
sorry no I was only going to say I know
that you're you're so Keen to make sure
that everybody else
um receives compensation like you and
that's your main message today but I am
interested to hear what it means to you
to receive a payment after as you say 35
years of having been infected as you
have
do you know at this moment in time and
I'm going to be honest with you I don't
really feel anything
um it's been a long fight and I although
I've only been in this for seven years
you know there's campaigners that have
been doing this for 30 years plus I
really take my hat off and thank them
for putting the hard-working at the
beginning I don't know how I feel about
it I don't know it can't bring back it
will never reverse the damage to my body
that that's been caused so it's a bit
surreal it's something that never was
definitely never gonna happen it's been
an inquiry you know we've campaign we've
campaigned so hard people have died
while they're campaigning one person is
still dying every 96 hours you know that
hasn't stopped so will I be around by
the end
um when the final compensation comes who
knows
um I've been left with liver cirrhosis
so I'm a potential candidate to get
sorry to interrupt you I'm so good to
hear from you but we're just about to
fall off air so I have to wrap it up
Michelle Tully thank you thank you very
much thank you bye-bye